I'm so delighted to be here today with
Cynthia Lowen the producer of the widely
acclaimed and really important new
documentary bully and the co-editor of
the book by the same title both of which
out our nation's dirty little secret
about bullying in schools across America
both the movie and the book put a human
face on what it's about
how it impacts kids on both sides and on
the sidelines and their families so
thank you so much Cynthia for being here
today why don't we start with you
telling us a little bit about yourself
how did you get get here how did you get
drawn to the issue why bully why you why
now well I come from a background as a
writer and when I was in middle school I
was one of those kids who was really shy
I think I tried to sail under the radar
and I was someone who I sobbing taking
place around me and I didn't know what
to do about it and as all of us I think
in this country were starting to see
people coming out and talking about
their experience of this phenomenon that
so many of us had experienced in one way
or another and had had no words for
other than adolescents other than
growing up when finally people were
starting to stand back and say hold on
this isn't actually normal part of
growing up this isn't a normal rite of
passage I think there was a moment where
there was a possibility for change and
director Lee Hirsch and I to start
decided to start the film out of that
feeling that voices were kind of
bubbling up coming up to the surface to
say this isn't something that we can
accept anymore
as a normal part of our culture so in
the spring of 2009 in April of that
month it was right after two young
people took their own lives Shaheen
Herrera outside Atlanta and Karl Walker
Hoover and Springfield Massachusetts
and both of those tragedies really I
think ignited a national recognition of
what what had been going on for so long
and we were seeing parents writing in to
message boards we were seeing on every
news story that came up you read in the
comment section hundreds of comments
from parents saying my child is going
through this from kids writing in
themselves saying I'm going through this
and I feel hopeless and helpless and I
don't know what to do from educators
writing in and saying we don't know how
to handle this we don't have the tools
to respond to this and we decided at
that time to start meeting the kids and
families and educators who are really on
the front lines of this issue so why
what's the difference between like
teasing and bullying is is everything
bad that happens to a kid bullying or is
it and there's some like global
definition of bullying that that really
works
yeah I think everyone will be teased and
I think that we all in our lives teach
each other I think that there's there
are things that are you know
good-natured and teasing as part of our
way of communicating with each other and
not all bullying not every fight is a
case of bullying there are instances
where there will be conflict where two
kids may fight there will be violence
and that's not necessarily bullying it
is bullying when there's an indifference
in power when the target does not have
the ability to make it stop when it is
something that is going on over time
continued abuse which the end game is to
isolate them to alienate them to
humiliate them and to prevent them from
being part of the community and and is
bullying something that is
mainly or just about words is it just
physical is it a combination today I
think we're seeing it takes all
different kinds of forms something that
parents often ask me is is bullying
worse today than it ever has been before
and I think that we've heard a lot about
cyber bullying there's a lot of
awareness growing around the ways in
which bullying is is finding sort of new
platforms and new ways to take place and
while that is absolutely a significant
piece of the picture the good old
fashioned bullying is still quite alive
and well so I think that it's something
that is happening in physical
interactions in bully we see a child who
every time he gets on his school bus
he's pretty likely to know that he's
going to be shoved by someone who's only
pushed by someone he may be public
pencils or pushed out of a seat he's
going to hear things people are going to
call him names and I think that's
something that's that's very prevalent
among girls so it can it can be
ostracism it can be everyone in a grade
is decided to throw a party and somehow
you know you're made very aware that you
were not invited to this so social
exclusion is a big part of it and then
again online passing pictures spreading
rumors so I think that it takes a lot of
a lot of different forms I think what
underscores bullying and I think why it
is so hard to work out is that it's
about social dynamics it's about social
hierarchies and the relationships
between kids and adolescents as you're
growing up particularly in middle school
where they're jockeying for power where
they're figuring out how to use their
social power it's complicated the the
child who may be the most popular person
on their sports team may be the same
person who's bullied when they get on
their bus so it reflects I think the
social dynamics of a group
dynamics are always changing so I think
that's part of what makes it really not
just kind of one one thing that we can
say oh this is bad we need to stomp it
out wherever we see it I think we have
to understand what's taking place among
kids who are really sophisticated in a
lot of understanding the dynamics of who
has power who doesn't so how prevalent
is bullying how can you give us some
information about like how likely
children generally are to face bullying
and also whether there are special
populations of kids who are particularly
vulnerable absolutely um we know that 13
million kids will be bullied in the
United States this year last year that's
that's a lot of kids we know that kids
who are LGBT are four times more likely
to be bullied than other kids and that's
kids who are gay lesbian transgender
bisexual happening or perceived to be
absolutely that's another kids don't
necessarily have to identify as gay to
pee to be picked on her or harassed for
not fitting gender stereotypes that is
another big part of the picture another
population that is very durable our kids
with autism a very high number of kids
on the autism spectrum are bullied often
kids who are at the high what they call
high-functioning autism they're
mainstreamed into schools so they have
great grades they look like everybody
else and yet they have a disability
that's invisible and which plays out in
social contexts of not understanding
social signs of not understanding that
the behaviors that someone may be doing
our bullying and not our not friendship
um so those are the three very at risk
and you described in the book that that
kids with special needs for them
is really a pandemic it's that prevalent
yeah absolutely
mm-hmm you know one of the things from
kids with autism kids with learning
disabilities kids with dyslexia we have
an essay by Joe Pantoliano who talks a
bit about having gone through his
adolescence and there being kind of
bullying all over the place and it's
playing out in different ways in this
community but realizing later in life
that he's dyslexic and I think a lot of
adults will now now that we I think have
a lot more awareness about learning
disabilities look back on their time
going through middle school going
through high school where they were
considered to be stupid or not
intelligent or made fun of for what we
now understand is learning disability
and just to clarify for the viewers
who's Joe Pantoliano he is a well-known
actor who is probably most well known
for his role in The Sopranos there's a
sort of irony irony about alright and
and you mentioned of junior high school
kids is there a subset and during your
high school that's particularly
vulnerable well what we know about
what's happening in junior high and what
makes it such a hot spot for bullying is
that kids brains are changing the
literally like they're sort of frontal
cortexes is rearranging their behaviors
are more impulsive they any of us who
have been there or who have kids who are
there can feel like my child to turn
into a total alien a lot a lot of
emotion a lot of hormones a lot of just
really learning how to process things
and what happens in that phase is that
you can make a lot of decisions that you
look back on later and say gosh like I
really didn't think that one through
another thing that's really happening at
that point is the influence of peers is
becoming more important than the
influence of family or parents so
there's a real shift that takes place
and who the kind of important elements
are and where they're looking to for
support and for acceptance and I think
that's what really makes some of the the
jockeying for power for popularity
really feel like this kind of almost
life-or-death thing when you're in law
school if you've been ostracized um no
one will sit with you no one invites you
to things that can feel like the entire
world is turned against you and I think
that with what we see taking place
online and on the internet that sense
that the entire world knows something
about your spread a rumor about you or
doesn't like you can feel can really
snowball very quickly when messages are
being spread on Facebook or text
messaging and stuff of that mm-hm so if
it's really about a difference kids who
are perceived as weaker perhaps and
different perhaps in whatever way shape
or form it is I'm sure that there's
bullying that goes on of kids who are
perceived as overweight or underweight
or or of one national national origin or
another I know here in New York we had
several incidents where some sick kids
si KH were targeted by bullies and and
and physically assaulted so it's about
really a way of not coming to terms with
differences is there anything about the
families of kids who are bullied that
that allows any sort of you know
conclusions to be drawn or does this cut
across like all different kinds of
family I think families are huge part of
the picture across the spectrum across
the spectrum of kids who are believed
those who are bystanders and those
who manifest bullying behaviors and I
think that's one of the things that is
really needed when we look at the
leading we can't just focus on what
happens for the hours that kids are at
school I think that there's been a huge
amount of pressure put on educators to
address bullying when they see in their
schools there are laws passed to varying
degrees of effectiveness that have
really mandated that schools must be
aware of this issue they must be
providing professional development and I
think we've gotten to a point over a
very short period of time
really since 2009 where I think schools
see their responsibility in regards to
this issue in a totally different light
that said I think that bringing parents
into the fold and working with parents
on this remains really difficult I think
that schools are scared that if they
admit that there's a bullying problem
taking place that they'll be attacked or
that they may be liable to lawsuits I
think they feel very vulnerable in their
ability to say we have a problem here we
need help we need tools and we're trying
to work on this so I think that parents
of kids can can be empowered in a lot of
different ways I think that one of the
things that we've seen bully is that
Alex doesn't tell his parents and this
is absolutely what happens parents do
not necessarily know what's going on
with their kids when they walk onto
their bus when they're at school
and I think that often kids will know
when their parents are under stress if
there's a lot going on at home and
parents are busy if you know the
communication isn't great or even if the
communication is great often kids are
ashamed they're afraid that either their
parents won't take them seriously or if
they do take them seriously that they're
going to march into school and do
something that's going to make the
situation even worse
and in situations where kids don't trust
that the adults are going to be able to
make the situation better or make it
stop without actually making them feel
more alienated or making the bullies
know that they've told someone in such a
way that now it's going to get even
worse kids don't want to tell and I
think the kids often don't necessarily
even want to perceive what's going on is
bullying so I think that one of the
things for parents who suspect their
kids might be bullied or any parent is
to find ways to talk to their kids about
what's going on at school in a way that
isn't necessarily saying are you being
bullied well you know you raise a an
interesting point it kind of rolls off
the tongue finding ways to talk to your
kid about what's going on in school and
to identify whether there's bullying
going on but I think that it's probably
fair to say that most parents would
would give their left arm to know how to
do that what kind of suggestions do you
have for parents to help their kids talk
to them I think it gets harder as kids
get older and very much want
independence and they want to be able to
handle situations on their own and so I
think that at different levels the
questions and the conversations can be
more or less direct I think for kids who
are at younger stages or at the end of
elementary school it can be much easier
to broach the topic questions or
conversations about you know who fits in
with a group who's sort of playing with
whom who seems to be ostracized I think
those questions can be answered more
directly for kids who are younger I
think when kids get to middle school
it's more roundabout I think one way of
getting a sense of what the social
fabric looks like at a school is asking
questions about cliques I think kids are
fascinated by changing cliques changing
social dynamics how different groups
identify themselves I think asking some
questions or kind of getting a sense
through conversations about what what's
that social fabric looking like where do
you feel like you fit in where do you
feel like you're not wanted for who are
you intimidated by right there can you
give us examples of questions that you
think work for kids we all know that you
know are you being bullied in school
does not work yes because they're like
no I think questions around things like
drama is there drama going on in your
group if you have a group of kids over
and you notice that someone's not there
where where is Jeanine today what's
going on with her
is everything okay between you two
I think the question some of the
questions that I brought up before how
do kids kind of break down who's wearing
what how do what what do you call the
different kids in their groups how do
they identify and what are some of the
things that that they do together that
they don't do or who's part of that
group simple questions like who who do
sit was at lunch some kids will be open
to answering that someone but I think
that those are some ways to get into it
after school activities what are some of
the things that are available what
interests you if your child was
interested in something and then
suddenly seems to be withdrawing from
that I would definitely probe a little
further maybe it's just that their
passions changed their interests change
that's happening all the time but maybe
it's because there's a group dynamic
within that activity that's become toxic
somehow but when when you say that that
it's the responsibility that bet all
parents and we know well parents want to
know what goes on in school and all
parents have a tough time finding out
that's the given but but
the object of finding out what's going
on in school is in part to know whether
your kids is is being hurt
terrorized bullied but it's also I would
imagine important for for all parents
whether or not their kids are being able
to find out what their kids role is in
the social fabric parents I'm sure that
there are lots of parents who think
their kids are perfectly happy in school
and it turns out that they may have like
you know they may be a bully now so so
questions like you know you know what's
the atmosphere like on the school bus
you know one people bus like is that fun
with the people hated or where you sit
on the school bus yeah that's a great
question I think that you'll find a lot
of kids will sit in my school bus you
didn't go to the back of a school bus
unless you really wanted to like get it
so I always out of the front of the
school bus because I was like terrified
of what was going on back there and you
know so I think I think that's a great
question you can learn a lot about what
that little ecosystem like is like there
by what's going on where you sit where
does it seem not really safe where do
you feel safe um I also think parents
kind of know a lot more about the social
dynamics within the groups of kids that
will come to their house after school or
that they'll see on the weekends or that
they'll drive I think just like being
involved in your child's life and making
sure that you know they're there for
dinner every night I think family
dinners are a really important time
where it's possible for parents to be
there often it's not possible when
parents are working or have other
commitments but I think making that time
to make sure that there's a safe place
at home where even when you know I
remember when I was in high school you
know I really
I'd go through times with their parents
but the last thing in the world I wanted
to do is get down to dinner but I knew
that that's what we did every night and
just by the fact that we were going to
spend that time together things come out
so I think that I think it's important I
think right now there are incredible
pressures on families and I think it can
be very very difficult to be able to
take the time to just sort of stop and
put down the iPhone and put it on the
computer turn the TV off and just sort
of be present and I think that that's
one way that just sort of some of those
implement information feelings and
patterns or things that seem to be out
of whack often will arise now when you
are making the documentary there came a
moment when when you took off your
filmmaker hat that was with Alex
yeah tell us about that we have been
following Alex as you know through the
school year and we're aware that he was
being bullied on her school bus and it
was something that was escalating over
the course of the school year we had let
the school know early in the school year
on the very first day that he had been
punched on on the bus on his first ride
to school and the response was sort of
you know yeah school buses
school buses are pretty rough they're
bad but nothing was done and as we were
witnessing Alex getting bullied more
severely over the course of the year and
as we knew things were happening when we
weren't there we came to a point where
we knew that on the one hand our
responsibility to the film in a
partnership with Alex who've been going
through this for years since elementary
school on the one hand the
responsibility to the film is to be able
to say this is what kids are going
through this is what it looks like and
we're not going to gloss this over on
the other hand or responsible
is to Alex into the family when the
school didn't intervene after we
continued to tell them that the dynamic
on the bus was dangerous for him we
decided that we had to show them the
footage and to make sure that they knew
exactly what we were talking about so
you're a top-flight filmmaker but you're
a person first and and you made the
decision to abandon your filmmaker
posture and become the responsible
bystander that you talked about in the
movie and in the book who can be so
important in in getting things under
control and helping should not be
victimized by bullying there's one group
of people that I just want to ask about
quickly which is a school resource
officers school safety officers allow
you to post Leafs in schools that they
operate with a lot of different hats on
just quickly before we take a quick
break what role do they play and are
they sometimes part of the problem well
in Alex's school there was a school
resource officer two doors down from the
assistant principal who didn't report
any of the salt and eat any of this
behavior to the school resource officer
I think the school resource officer in
in case of the bullying can be a great
resource not that you want to create a
record for someone in middle school but
you want them to know there are real
consequences to this behavior and the
consequences only get realer as you get
older so they're real liaison I think
between the consequences that behaviors
can have when kids are younger and are
changing and are making an impulsive
decisions and their ability to say you
know what I I have to be responsible for
my actions and these are not behaviors
that I can do so the response of the
adults who are supposed to be there
helping kids protecting them respecting
them is really critical isn't it can you
learn to to what happens to these kids
all right
I think we'll take a quick break now and
we'll come back and talk more about some
of the solutions to the problem this is
bullying is is it's probably easier to
spot than it is to fix and I think that
if we if we don't take a comprehensive
approach sometimes we can make things
worse by by bumbling yep and our kids
are too precious to bumble with aren't
they
okay so we'll take a break now and we'll
be right back great thank you
on the go afterwards is available via
podcast through iTunes and XML visit
book TV org and click podcasts on the
upper left side of the page select which
podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel
so let's just talk a little bit more
about the school resource officers and
school safety officers more thought
absolutely I think that they can play a
really important role in these scenarios
when they start to escalate into
situations where you have text messaging
where it's being where bullying is
happening over Facebook or where it is
involving more serious incidents of
physical assault one thing that I think
parents find is that when they have
tried to resolve a situation through
through the school or through they've
gone to a Facebook safety page and have
reported what's taking place on Facebook
and it's still continuing I think that
turning to police for help is something
that can be a really important step for
parents to take however I think what
often happens is that these instances
are looked at as something that is sort
of taking place among kids that it's
beneath the role of the police
department to deal with I think the
perception can often be that they have
much more important things to deal with
even for school resource officers often
their role is more to be working with
kids who are already in the juvenile
justice system to serve as liaison
within the schools for issues like that
and not necessarily dealing with
behavioral things as they come up I
think that if schools can partner with
police departments to educate them about
bullying to work together about
investigating instances of cyberbullying
many police departments in the United
States now are developing Cyber Crimes
Unit
so that they're equipped to say okay we
can figure out where this message came
from what the computer's IP address was
and they can figure out where some of
these things are coming from I think
that can be a really helpful tool for
parents who have gotten to that point
where they feel helpless and like
they've investigated a lot of the alleys
that they have to try and resolve a
situation that is precious and
persistent and so so where you have
police officers stationed in a school in
New York City for example there are
5,000 of them do you ever hear about how
they interact with students and are
there ever problems with school safety
officers actually being both serving as
bullies themselves I'm sure there are
instances you know there are instances
where teachers are found to be bullying
and harassing their students I think
that absolutely those things happen and
I think that we don't want to have
officers in our schools to intimidate
kids we want officers in our schools in
the situations where they're needed to
keep kids safe or to provide some kind
of helpful direction that helps them
resolve things before they get to a
point where they are 18 years old and
they are at risk of having a record that
can really damage them for life so how
do you inoculate the the the officers
and the teachers for that matter against
being part of the problem how do what it
was important for them by way of rules
or training to to ensure that they have
the tools and also that they're
accountable for for protecting the kids
and helping them through this well I
think it's the same thing that comes
down to what happens in a building where
all of the adults in the building take
bullying seriously and it's about
culture I don't think that it's about
you know
we don't we're not going to do these
five behaviors because those are
bullying I think it's about looking at
the overall picture of what is the
culture and climate in the school and I
think that one of the things that we
know is that strong leadership really
starts at the top that principals have a
great deal of influence over how all of
the adults in their building treat not
only the kids but each other there are
buildings like the school that we saw in
bully like East Middle where you have a
principal who intimidates all of the
people underneath in this case it was
amend underneath him and so what
happened in that school was that it was
normal for people to feel scared it was
normal for people to feel intimidated
and because the teachers and even the
assistant principal felt it herself
there was not a ton of empathy when they
saw it taking place among the kids
because it was something that just
seemed like an inevitable part of the
social fabric of those school however
when you're in a school where the
leadership is very different where
there's a more lateral approach where
people feel safe where the hierarchy is
not very stringent and constantly
reinforced there's a lot more
opportunity for kids to be protected and
there's a lot more opportunity for
adults to say I need resources I need
help I need support and to get the kinds
of tools that they need so for instance
in an Alex's situation again we saw that
his bus driver saw this going on we know
she thought going on we know she heard
it but she didn't pull over
bus drivers recess aides those who serve
lunches to our kids are often in the
school's hierarchy at kind of the low
end of the totem pole they're not
incorporated into the leadership in the
school they're not incorporated in the
same way and supported in the ways that
teachers are and as a result of which
they often don't feel like they can take
the time out or will be supported if
they say stop the bus deal with it well
then what happens when they're 15
minutes late to school you know so I
think that
I think that it's about realizing that
everyone not just SRO officers not just
teachers have a really big role to play
in this and then often the so-called hot
spots in schools are those that are kind
of looked over by those who are given
the least amount of authority and when
kids recognize that someone isn't being
respected by the other adults in the
building they don't give those people
their respect either so so the hot spots
those are the cafeteria and and maybe
the locker room and the school bus and
and those are places to watch out for
and it's also essential for the school
principal to make sure that that not
just that the the folks who work in
those places the adults who were there
are accountable for what goes on but
that they have that they know that they
have the opportunity to be heard and the
obligation to speak with at a school
leadership about what's going on that's
a really I think important point you
know there are so many different players
in in our society and therefore in the
issue of bullying why don't you give us
a couple of tips like what is give us a
couple of tips that a student can do to
to reduce the likelihood of bullying or
to you know respond in a bullying
situation well I think this is one of
the reasons why we wanted to create this
book because one of the things that we
do in the film is that I think we do a
good job of making people aware of the
extent to which this is happening that
it's a crisis and that it's not okay to
accept what we wanted to do with the
book was to be able to provide people a
place to go to when you get to that
point where you're you see the film and
you say okay
we need tools to do this now what are
those tools so one of the things that a
number of the contributors to the book
talk about are what can you do from
various perspectives from the
perspective of appearance and their
perspective of kids who are either
bullied or bystanders or perhaps even
bullies themselves and from the
perspective of educators so I think one
of the things from the kids perspective
is that there's a lot of power in
numbers and I think that where you can
have a social dynamic where if you're a
young person who knows that you have
some social cachet in your in your
circle in your social dynamic you may
feel more comfortable than those around
you you may feel more competent I think
for kids who have that confidence and
who know that they're influential among
their peers I think for those kids to be
educated about bullying for them to say
I want to be a student leader and I am
committed to standing up one of the one
of the contributors to the book Randi
Weingarten talks about the be brave
against bullying initiative and that
there are wristbands that the American
Federation of Teachers has made
available so that any teacher who wants
to can get the wristband online and they
are now displaying a visible sign that
kids know that they are a safe person to
go to that there's someone who has made
a decision to prevent bullying and to
respond to it when they see it and I
think visible signs like that not only
for teachers and for administrators I
think that those are really effective
but I think also for young people there
are a number of different kinds of
creative things that you can do to make
a visible sign to say I'm a safe person
for you to go to if you're being
targeted by bullying it one of the
things that
educators talk about is how kids like to
be competent and they like to be helpful
and and I was impressed by the story in
the book about how from Mike Mulgrew
who's the president of the UFT Inn in
New York City when he was teaching he
would would identify kids who were at
risk and bring them into his classroom
and ask his class to support them and
work with them it seemed like you know
kind of a common sense but brilliant
yeah approach to to making everybody
part of the solution solution and
raising all the votes absolutely and one
of the things that we see often with
kids who have special needs have
learning disability or autism so often
the philosophy is to help give those
kids tools to not be targeted or to make
them less likely to be targeted and like
avoiding certain situations yeah um you
know to avoid certain areas in school
you know that we know kids are
vulnerable in where there is little
supervision but I think that's only one
piece of yeah because I think that a
little bit of a cop-out right if if
these kids had the the social skills so
many of the disabilities like with
autism that make them more likely to be
bullied are are is a social disability
so I think that one of the things we
have to do a better job of and I think
that Michael Mulgrew is si speaks to
this is how do you educate the entire
community about disabilities like autism
or like like learning disabilities so
that it's not up to the person who
already is struggling to keep up or
who's already struggling to navigate
these complex social hierarchies to make
sure that everyone else knows autism
this is what autism looks like this is
why autism kids with autism may respond
differently this is why someone with
autism they have a tick or do behaviors
that you know I I don't understand but I
student happening you know how can we
get kids to be more
of the differences among them and to say
okay we're going to support this person
and not ostracize them or pick on them
because they're different now we
understand that our what's going on
isn't some of this about building
empathy touch with that absolutely I
think this was why our approach to the
film was what it was and it's why we
wanted to bring that same approach to
the book we feel that this is an issue
that so many of us I know is going on we
know the numbers are extraordinary of
kids who are being bullied but I think
what it comes down to is really
understanding what it means to have to
wake up every day and to know you're
going to go to school and to know that
you're scared about what's going to
happen to you there so many of the
people who have not only contributed to
the book with the people who were in the
film had never had the opportunity to
tell their story before because either
there was no one there to listen or it
wasn't recognized as a problem or
because they were ashamed or scared and
what we what we wanted to do with this
film was to give people the opportunity
to respond to this issue and to move
hearts and minds with the power of story
and I think that you know that's another
another thing that has been effective
not only in bullying but really within
empowering kids and helping to build
bridges so so you know one of the
standard and unhelpful I think responses
to you know when one child hurts another
and including bullying is say you're
sorry
mm-hm what do you think about that right
and we know that in most cases someone
is told to say they're sorry they're not
sorry that they did something to hurt
another person they're sorry that they
got caught so and that's something of
course again that we see in the film and
what's the effective way to to
bring the kids together to build the
understanding that that makes the the
child who has done the bullying you know
understand the impact of what they've
done and for there to be a positive
outcome yeah I by and large the kids who
are involved in bullying behaviors
they're not bad kids
they're kids who maybe have made a bad
choice they're kids who maybe were under
a lot of social pressure and wanted to
fit in with what the people around them
were doing and I think that most kids
have a pretty profound capacity for
empathy one of the things that happened
with Alex and we touched on this a
little bit following up with the kids in
the book after the film came out of you
know what happened for everyone
one of the really incredible things that
happen with him is that when we screened
the film in Sioux City for the entire
community sixteen hundred people came
out for the film wasn't beaters the
principal the assistant from everyone
came out and after the film some of the
kids who had been involved with bullying
him sent him posted on the bully project
page on YouTube posting that they were
sorry about what they had done he
received letters from some of the kids
who had bullied him so so often I think
what can happen is that kids don't see
the entire picture they may shove
someone at the locker on their way to
class in the morning but what they don't
know is that that same person then was
called a name at lunch they were not
chosen to be at a team when they got
into gym class they you know had work
trips on their Hall tripping the hall on
the way to their other class and that
it's not often it's not these big huge
acts of violence that are the things
that I think can really wear young
people down and this was absolutely the
case with Tyler long David and Tina long
fun he took his own life but it was this
constant pervasive presence of these
smaller acts
and I think that when kids stop and get
to have an opportunity to look at the
whole picture to look at the things that
they didn't necessarily know we're going
on they have a different sense of how
their actions may have impacted that
person and I think that that's where a
lot of these stories come in where
academics a well I did nothing with them
I just you know is pushing them on the
bus like well you don't know kind of all
the other things that were happening
there so one of the I think various
aspects of bullying and dealing with
bullying is the potential for the
solution to be worse than the the
problem itself you know I think you
mentioned earlier that kids really are
afraid or reluctant to talk to their
parents for fear that they'll just come
in and get in the way and make things
worse more in teacher for that matter
you know and and so so but the solution
isn't easy it's not just say you're
sorry it's not just promise you won't do
this again how do you how do we
encourage what does it take to turn a
school around I think it's really hard I
think that there's no one program I
think that there's no you know silver
bullet as they say there's no
zero-tolerance policy if there are
tolerance of the thing I personally feel
that if zero tolerance is enacted
without comprehensive commitment to
professional development to working with
kids to creating peer mentorship
opportunities I think schools can
sometimes sort of put out that they have
a zero-tolerance policy but not do the
other work and feel like oh well we've
got our bases covered
more in the event that you know maybe
they have to they have liability or
something like that that they're worried
about but aren't really doing a
comprehensive work so I don't think it's
effective unless you actually
do a lot of the really details on work
of educating teachers educating bus
drivers educating everyone in the
building and having the kind of leader
who can enroll the adults and building
to all feel that this is something that
is a priority for that school
we know that in situations where you
don't have the support of the entire
school community bullying prevention
programs whatever they are will fail so
that's one thing that's really important
is enrollment among all the adults ah
and then as that reaches down to the
students I think one of the things that
we know is so critical with students and
that we know from how they work is that
the input of peers can often be more
influential than those of adults or
teachers so it can mean more when an
upperclassman is coming and speaking
with them about this is the kind of
culture that we have here and this is
how we resolve conflict come to me of
someone spreading a rumor about you and
we'll work this out and this is
something Rosalind Wiseman and Hayley
Kilpatrick created girls Inc also what
is it girl think well I may talk about
girl talk girl blonde desired an
something that she talks about with girl
talk is the importance of having older
girls who can come talk to younger girls
and say you know we all have gone
through this and it's really hard and
it's going to happen and we have to find
better ways to respond and to be
confident so I think that where you can
really get the ball rolling among kids
and again getting kids who who are
confident who can really start this and
can make being kind cooler than being
cruel has a lot of influence over the
entire school community and I think that
the third piece of the puzzle is really
getting parents involved something that
was one of the biggest surprises with
the film was when I went to get releases
from all the parents
every parent of the children in the film
find relief allowing their kids to be in
the film and as you can imagine the
conversations were really intense
particularly when the parents of the
kids who are doing some of the more
severe bullying saw the footage and
their response was not only to let their
kids be in the film because they wanted
them to learn from what had from what
they saw and to have the opportunity to
see themselves behaving in a way that
was really important they were surprised
that they hadn't been engaged by the
school to a greater extent about these
behaviors so I think that sometimes
schools can be hesitant to reach out to
parents of kids who are bullying because
they know it's like opening you know a
can of worms and you're going to have to
deal with parents who may be very
defensive parents may be very angry but
I think for parents who get those phone
calls sometimes that can be the best
phone call you get in your life because
if you don't know that these things are
happening if you don't know that you
know your sweet little child is getting
on the bus and being a tyrant you never
have the opportunity to address it
and it's in that context I think that
that your book talks about you know the
difference between punishment and
discipline mhm yeah absolutely I think
that that it's not about punishing in
such a way as to shut down the
conversation about how do we how do we
develop understanding how do we develop
them empathy how do we take
responsibility for our actions and I
think that that's really what the hope
is for an intervention that's effective
is that it doesn't only change the life
of the person who's being targeted but
hopefully it changes the life of the
person who is also perpetrating
behaviors you know I was I was
interested that that
you know there are a number of steps
that are you know laid out in terms of
the apology phase you know I think one
of the significant points that was made
is that this isn't about shame for
either the bully or the bullied but it's
really more about problem-solving and
and an understanding and a big a big
component here seems to be you know what
Aretha was talking about RESP CT all
around the school how do you make that
happen
I think a big part of it is really
honestly assessing what's going on in
our communities I think that again one
of the things that we notice in schools
is that where there is a lot of
hierarchy and stratification among the
adults you're likely to find a similar
kind of vibe among the kids and I think
that when it comes to respecting all the
members of our communities I think that
that really happens in a lot of places
it doesn't only happen in school it
happens online
it happens in what we're seeing in the
media it happens in the ways in which we
see our families treating each other
treating our neighbors and I think that
we have to really look at what are the
kinds of things that that were modeling
you mentioned before that after that
there's been a lot of bullying awareness
and a lot of targeting of Sikhs here in
New York City one of the very early film
shoots that we did was around a day of
where they were raising awareness about
the bullying harassment that they were
experiencing and largely it was as a
result of a lot of the racism and the
attacks that we were seeing in the wake
of 9/11
um and that Muslim kids were being
targeted see kids were being completed
with Muslim kids are being targeted and
that that was a real reflection of what
was going on nationally in our culture
in our consciousness in communities
where people no longer felt safe so it's
a big it's a big picture and I think
that I think that's why it's it's a kind
of tough nut to crack
it sure is what I'm hearing you say is
that that this is about creating a
school climate that is safe for all kids
that that all the kids and the adults in
the school at whatever level they're
working are part of the solution and you
can't just dismiss this as kids will be
kids you know or you know toughen up
this is really about fundamental dignity
and it's about it's unfortunately it's
about life and death for some kids and I
paint the wave of far too many young
people losing their lives to bullying by
suicide has been a wake-up call to all
of us your book and the movie have a lot
of resources in them you want to tell us
about your website and some resources
that are available in addition to the
New York Civil Liberties Union that has
done some important litigation around
these issues and advocacy what's your
website the website is www.seannal.com
with the film that provide opportunities
to get involved with the with the film
in with the social action campaign hang
on to get a book people can get the
look online your website again is the
bully project calm okay
and it's available on Amazon it's also
that's great so Amazon or the bully
project calm so this is interesting
and I want to congratulate you and thank
you on behalf of all parents and kids
think you have for the contribution
you've made to the well-being of all of
America's children thank you